I have to ask you about Star Wars they
are making the new Star Wars films you
are going to be involved no we must know
something we must you must give us
[Applause]
no no okay listen this is somethin I'm
gonna do who's gonna do I was preparing
this isn't fake money this is a real
thousand dollars right here this is a
thousand dollars okay it's not my money
I took it from Mandy's dressing room
this is a real thousand dollars I will
give you this money if you tell us
something about the new Star Wars film
[Applause]
a long time ago a long time ago in a
place far far away I forget the rest I
think it's a galaxy far far it's
actually a galaxy out it's a galaxy far
far away it was a long time it was a lot
in many ways it was a long give me any
detail at all it was really a long time
ago and it feels like it was far far
away
but I hear they're they're thinking of
doing another one
all right we're taking a break I'm
getting that money back somehow those
are something much more no 100 I'm such
an eating of any idea what they normally
pay you to come here and I thought you
came here out of the love Harrison just
the love for me no I don't go I stay
home for lo
[Music]
[Applause]